- IT TURNS OUT
IT WASN'T A GHOST AT ALL.
IT WAS MY LITTLE SISTER HIDING
IN THE BASEMENT!
AND SHE WAS GOIN' "BOO"
AND MAKING THE NOISES
THE WHOLE TIME, SO...
- OH, SHOOT.
I FORGOT HIS JUICE BOXES.
- OH.
- I WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT
WITH ZACHARY?
- I THINK SO.
- OKAY.
- SO, ZACHARY...
YOU KNOW I'M, UH, GONNA BE
MARRYING YOU MOTHER
AND, UH,
I'M GONNA BE MOVING IN SOON
AND I JUST...
I'M SO EXCITED
TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH YOU.
YOU KNOW,
I KNOW THAT YOU HAD A HARD TIME
WITH YOUR FATHER AND HE SPANKED
YOU AND, YOU KNOW,
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN WITH ME.
OKAY?
AND I PROMISE I
WILL NEVER SPANK YOU.
OKAY. THAT'S... OKAY.
UM...
I KNOW WHY YOU DID THAT.
BUT I WILL NEVER SPANK YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU STILL--
OH! THAT'S--
OW.
I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
I DID TO DESERVE THAT--OKAY.
THIS...YOU...OKAY.
MM. I'MA BE REAL WITH YOU.
YOU CAN'T GO HITTIN' PEOPLE.
ALL RI--OH! OH! OH!
I AIN'T COMING BACK
FOR THAT FOURTH ONE.
ALL RIGHT. SO WE DONE?
WE GOT THAT OUT OF OUR SYSTEM?
'CAUSE I KNOW THAT THIS...
THIS ISN'T YOU.
OH!
I TOLD YOU--UH! OH! OH! COME ON!
THIS...OH! OH! OH!
THIS...YOU...
UGH! UGH! WHY!
- FAST.
- OH WHAT?
OOH! UGH! OH!
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
WHY--WHAT DID I DO?
I'M THE GOOD GUY.
I'M--I'M THE GOOD GUY, MAN.
LOOK.
I'M NEVER GONNA SPANK YOU.
I'M NOT GONNA BE
LIKE YOUR FATHER.
I'M GONNA BE YOUR FRIEND.
YOU NEED TO RESPECT ME!
YOU UNDERSTAND?
YOU LITTLE [bleep]!
- I WILL RESPECT YOU, CHARLES.
IF YOU PLAY YOUR ROLE.
NOW, LISTEN UP...
I'M A BAD, BAD BOY, CHARLES.
I DON'T NEED A [bleep] FRIEND.
SO GO AHEAD.
MARRY MY MOMMY.
MOVE IN.
[bleep] HER AS HARD AS YOU WANT.
JUST LEAVE ME
THE [bleep] ALONE.
YOU DO THAT, 11 YEARS FROM NOW,
I'LL BE OUT OF THE HOUSE
AND WE WON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS.
YOU DON'T...
AND I WILL BREAK YOU.
OKAY, CHARLES?
- HOW ARE WE DOING?
- I LOVE HIM!